oh good that looks looks just like the
invite
we are at WWDC about the head and I just
got my credentials which means it's
official this is my first WWDC I've been
to WWDC s before but only outside of
like the Moscone Center I've never
actually been inside of an event my
first one today's the day I'm freaking
out I'm freaking out I'm so excited
let's go
[Applause]
oh man I'm so hyped but they are so
height it kind of looks like I'm talking
to myself this Jenna's kind of far away
but like I'm not this is gonna happen
quite a lot thank you
this is one of my favorite colors
hi good how are you it's going good up
great I'll see you okay it looks pretty
cool everybody has really big cameras
okay what's 8:30 everybody has Apple
bags some people shopping already I'm
not sure where to go I'm in ask somebody
here now in line but we've got like
almost two hours until the event I'm
gonna go get us some orange juice so
I'll be right back I'll report back
[Music]
so somebody actually got these for us in
line so we have to thank them he said
hey nice YouTube channel do you mean to
get that orange juice for you
Cheers
we're waiting very patiently through the
doors over and by patiently
I mean I'm shaking in my boots and I'm
not even where about
these are actually kids shoes
I saw the door just open a doors open
it's closed now
Wow okay okay okay let's go popular for
kids
can I walk in with you because we got in
the wrong line yeah and I almost was
going into risers and we were in the
wrong line before they called the
broadcast cameras for like the news I
guess that's why they were questioning
why our camera was so little so we made
a mistake but I just cut in line with
Marquez so I'm so sorry I'm supposed Ari
I'm sorry
it's beautiful yes that's a lot of apps
we made it here we are inside I'm so
excited it there's a huge massive screen
up at the front and it's all covered in
apps I wish that that's at my house look
like I mean it could my husband kind of
does look like that
I'm shaking I'm shaking in my shoes
[Applause]
corners of the world this is the
developments try to wraps us as it is
not commonly known the developer
WWDC 2018
it is great to be back in San Jose with
everyone we have developers here release
iOS is you guessed it
iOS 12 now tapping and dragging our line
like that and check that out it's a
measurement if I can extend these
measurements so I could just tap it
Simon so excited about this because I
can never find a measure
this is so cool they have category and
they collapse take a moment you could be
raised up to four friends so you say I
can't tell you it's now what they up to
we get to see inside office
appropriations just like to check out
all the details oh it hidden before a
ballerina first you choose you'd like to
enable walkie talkie with and it
suggests of people that you often
communicate with to get easily on them
now the first time that you do this your
friend will receive a one-time request
to allow a lot me talking connection
with you if the if they accept that you
can speak to each other with what you
talking whatever you like briefly
address this question no
like this only come from years of effort
and hard work and great sacrifice and so
I think them and their families let's
have an incredible week together thank
you
so we're just heading out of the actual
keynote it was so awesome there are so
many things I had to talk to you guys
about but I don't think that's gonna
happen in this particular video because
this is just a blog so there'll be tons
of videos coming on more of the things
but oh I'm so sorry but now it's time
for some lunch I think what do you think
lunch we're trying to get Jordan to get
an Apple watch so that I can walk the
talk of him like Jordan hello Jordan
hello if it it'd be really cool if it
actually worked out like shortwave radio
cuz in like a group of like a car fun
boy or something yes you can talk to
other people and other cars super-sweet
but if you look like Angelis press
there's no cell data there okay it
sounds cool
Jordan you're so particular you're just
leaving the keynote I had so much fun I
would have to say one of my highlights
it's probably which is so crazy and
random they have walkie talkie now on
the watch OS five I'm super excited
about it also dark mode which is
something that I've been looking forward
to for a really long time so that'll be
coming in the new back OS which is named
Mojave and guess what that means we've
been going to all of the places of the
Mac OS names like we went to and fun we
we did one to7 he went to El Capitan
like two years ago and now Jenna we're
going to Mojave baby
I guess I didn't have to do that okay
we're gonna go get some lunch I'll talk
to you guys more about what we saw I had
such a great time I can't wait for all
the new updates it was very very
software heavy I didn't think that there
was going to be a one more thing I had
something in my mind that I thought that
it was gonna be but there was it but
it's okay there will be more events
there will be more things so how many
videos have you seen of all of us saying
our one favorite thing that we're most
excited about I'm sure you've seen all
of us saying it but hey why not let's
just do it again
so hey Jonathan that's a favorite thing
walkie-talkies on an Apple watch not
right now but I'm gonna get one just for
that not right now I was waiting for
like the update and it hasn't happened
yet I was hoping I was gonna come out
today here's what I'm gonna say because
nobody else is gonna say this is super
underrated it's just like faster
performance why don't you say that in my
video but yeah like no one's like
talking about that was true like things
are opening faster the camera and stuff
like it's not exciting but it's
definitely useful I'd have to go with
desktop stacks dad it's a clutch I keep
a super super dirty desktop I usually
throw everything in one fold
but desktops faster definitely change
that up wait a minute I forgot there's a
32 person FaceTime we need to get 32 of
us it's gonna be the best collab ever
all on a FaceTime call we're gonna start
a Google Doc and we're gonna make this
happen I'm not gonna promise because I
don't know if I'll be able to deliver
right now we playing swift shot and
playing against Jordan and this game is
all built in a are using AR kit - what's
cool about Erica - is you can play with
multiple people you can play across time
spans so you can come back to a game if
you decide to leave it and also there is
spectators so right now as you can see
over here we have someone who is
spectating their game so he can see what
we see because really if you really look
there's nothing there are you ready
Oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
so sorry yeah I know me I guess
well it was technically one-to-one like
overall then but now would be two to one
no no game didn't really finish so you
didn't quite it's more like it's a super
fun game what did you think I thought
was awesome I mean just to see that
world that you can't really see in real
life like it's very strange to like be
playing a game that's just not existing
in front of you but I really liked it it
took me a little bit of it took me a
little bit to get the hang of it you can
go hands-free it's magical well it's
good to see you I feel like I run into
randomly at all these random events
usually yeah once a year twice a year
you know we probably live like it's true
yeah in LA but we see each other
elsewhere that's how it is it would take
like two hours to get to anywhere in LA
I didn't feel like a mile away what was
your favorite things in the keynote uh
to me my personal favorite was actually
that we can now have Google Maps and
ways on par play me too nobody's really
like caring about it except me because I
love Apple maps everything I think it
looks so beautiful like Chloe but
sometimes I just want my Google Maps
it's true yeah I love carplay I love it
so much I was actually excited about the
greatest thing ever
I was excited I'm about being able to
track yoga workouts oh yeah watch
analyst are all automatic and like you
don't just start anything it's just
everything the phone is just doing
everything you don't think anymore it's
so right I'm looking forward to that too
there's so many fun things not the yoga
just the automatic track well maybe I
don't
like that okay that brings my WGC vlog
to a close I'll be doing a bigger recap
and talking about some of the other
things that I've seen here and of course
the announcements but for now that's the
end of the vlog and I will see you guys
soon hope you guys enjoyed it I had it
the absolute best time I'll see you
later bye
[Music]